ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show
here live
from a stunning estate
out here in the desert uh this is a
temporary setup for the show for the
moment
we are looking at studio spaces right
now
uh haven't made any commitment to
anything yet
obviously we are like many of you
um quite uncertain
about um what's going to be open
what's going to be usable state of
california considering another
shutdown you're going to get a video
podcast from somewhere
and you're going to like it because it's
free that's what's going to happen
it's not on [ __ ] zoom like everybody
else is doing
i don't have an uninteresting guest
coming on over zoom
okay to tell you about what it's like in
in the hell they find themselves in it's
a pretty
good deal for nothing
you don't spend a dollar i'm excluding
of course
the patreon members who support the show
and don't get video because patreon is
audio audio only because
it is a throwback to the 90s golden era
of talk
radio where you didn't need to look at
somebody
you were driving on the cross island
parkway and you were you were just
waiting to get home and choke your wife
out
and so you listen to bob grant and rush
limbaugh or if you were
late night you might listen to art bell
people talk about aliens which we'll
talk about later
but i grew up on those shows i grew up
on right
wing reactionary talk radio
it was a beautiful great thing for this
country
and morning shows comedy comedic morning
shows
but bob grant was the best whether you
liked his politics or nod
he would always tell people who would
call into a show he'd go you're a fake
phony fraud get off my phone and he'd
hang up
and they'd call back every week it was
fun
so that's why you don't need the video
on patreon it's an homage
to a better time we didn't have to
see everything visually joe rogan
announced that he's moving to texas
and i want to get this i want to get
this
uh out because i i think there's a lot
of people
that don't know the full story joe
wants to go there for a little more
freedom he said and because
la you know you have the homelessness
and the traffic here's the actual
reality
i moved to la about a year ago and i
immediately started making more money
than joe
on as a podcaster i was i'm doing better
than him
our youtube views are higher than his uh
my subscribers are more than his
my ad deals are more than his um in the
beginning that was okay but it became
awkward for us for our friendship
it was weird to see him at the comedy
store um
because i was making more money as a po
i was a bigger podcaster
in a year of being in los angeles um my
our podcast regularly get 30 to 50
million views
per podcast and he gets i believe
maybe 2 million or 5 million or
something it's
pathetic so he's now running to texas
he's running away from me because i have
taken over los
angeles and i am the biggest podcaster
in the world
and i you know for him to go out and
pretend that this is about
traffic is a little absurd um i
i came i saw i conquered and he is
choosing to run away
that's the reality he doesn't have any
money he asked me to borrow 300
last week and i said no um
that's it i i will not enable people in
their poor decisions uh this spotify
deal is not real spotify does not exist
i have google spotify i don't know what
it is
i don't think by the way neither does
spotify if they exist they don't know
what it is
i don't know what it is i don't know
what this last podcast on the left is
that got some d i don't know what these
things are
i'm pretty sure they're inventions i
don't fall for it
okay so when i come to la and i take it
over
just admit that you got beat
don't start talking about homeless
people in traffic
okay i'm number one now number one you
hear that
hashtag only comedy store regular not in
jail
it's a joke relax
[Music]
i never knew what i never thought i'd
know what it felt like to own a city
now i do out i'll be deciding who stays
and who goes
[Music]
boy this thing we we made a couple of
videos for tbs today
that i mean we don't really respect the
tournament of laugh show
but i mean the the level of
just complete indifference
to the to the videos even making the
least bit of sense
i mean they don't make any sense and
we've delivered them to tbs
with pretty much a 24-hour turnaround
time where they
have to edit these videos into some
coherent narrative these sketches don't
make any sense at all we're going to
play them
next week as soon as we get the go-ahead
to play these full sketches for you i
really want to tell you what we've done
because we have done something i mean we
should be
blacklisted from the business like
harvey weinstein
for the level of uh sketch we
delivered to tbs for their uh
show tournament of laughs of course
where
comedians i don't know how many they
started with but we're the we're in
where
are we in the can we say what we're in
now i think so we're in the final we're
in the final round
we're in the final round we've already
won
la now we're going to try to win
tournament of laughs but the sketches
that we've submitted
they're funny because they make
absolutely no sense
um and and i cannot wait to show you the
raw footage that we sent to tbs i'm very
curious
as to what they will do with it i mean
in one of the sketches
i'm in a colorful shirt i'm wearing a
wig
i'm standing in the shower and i'm just
i say i'm anthony fauci's son and i just
start yelling
forget about it and coronavirus forget
about it
and that's the entire sketch that's
it okay in the shower
fouchy sun there's i'm getting rained on
i mean the showers
making me wet and i'm going hey forget
about it coronavirus forgot about it
we sent that to tbs today they didn't
understand what it was
but they kind of have to put it on
television
which is what makes us laugh television
is now a
practical joke
we wanted to get on television at one
point now we run from it like a like a
coughing [ __ ] corona patient
i'm telling you television has now
become
you know my aunt had a great quote about
tournament of laughs she goes
your video doesn't seem as funny
because it's on that show
and then she goes i watched it on social
media and it's great
but on that show it doesn't seem funny
and that's the problem
with television right now too many cooks
in the god damn kitchen but we gave
those cooks this week a bowl of [ __ ]
and they're going to have to make up a
pie
with that good luck forget about
when i tell you that that's the whole
sketch
it's three minutes when i tell you i
splash around in a bathtub going
forget about anthony fauci daddy fauci
i mean they should just
they should not air it and fire me
they should fire us they should email
us and go you're fired we know what
you're doing you disrespectful piece of
[ __ ]
what you think you don't need us cause
you got a hundred thousand views on a
podcast you
fat big go into new media you
[ __ ] loser you pirate ship
steering scum go steer your pirate ship
and go live in a car
that's what they should do but instead
they're gonna put it on television
they're gonna put it on television and
joe rogan can watch it in texas from his
trailer park
because we've won
spotify google the spotify doesn't exist
are they nuts these people they love
they don't stop
lying they make up a hundred million
three hundred million it's all fake it's
not
real if spotify was real they would have
bought
my show
congrats to nicholas sandman
the covington catholic student who
settled a lawsuit today with the
with the uh washington post
i believe it was a 250 million dollar
lawsuit i don't know what
does that mean he gets 250 what does it
mean benjamin
break it down ben avery legal scholar
what does it mean
so they did settle but they haven't
disclosed the terms of the deal
we don't know the terms of the deal but
it's good money is it not
it must be is it big money it's probably
really big
i bet it's big money for
nicholas sandman covington catholic high
school teen of the heart
of the this is when the native american
if you don't remember this folks
uh remember you were somewhere when the
world was a world
you were in your office you're maybe
eating a cold
crazy sandwich this is where you were i
know where you were
you were eating a cold caprese sandwich
which has
the tomato and the tomato had a little
bit of the
white in the middle because it was
winter and you don't love that but it's
the way it is because you just grabbed
this
from the deli in the building you know
the [ __ ] food place in the building
you're eating a caprese sandwich you're
dunking it
it's got a light smear of pesto but you
needed more so you're dumping it in the
balsamic vinegar
and you're eating it and you're really
like god this isn't good it's just not
good it tastes like refrigerator
and you're eating it and then you looked
online and
uh you saw this
story about uh a group of red hat
maga hat wearing kids from covington
catholic a school in kentucky that went
to the march for life in dc
and surrounded a native american man and
beat him to death
because that's what i thought happened
when i first saw how angry everybody was
i said they surrounded this native
american man who was like trying to sing
peaceful songs that the native american
man was like peace to all the people
in the world i don't know why he's
british
but the accents never come out the way
they
should but it's good because it's a
white accent and you can't get angry at
that
so this is nathan phillips with his drum
and his british agony ghost and he walks
up to the castle
yes i'm a british indian
and i love you and then the kids
beat the [ __ ] out of him stomp on his
head
piss in his mouth [ __ ] him not because
they're gay it's just
showing of power i [ __ ] him smirk him in
his face
uh bloody him up real good take a [ __ ]
on him
um and then i don't know
and then like light his corpse on fire
and all light [ __ ] joints
uh and then smoke them and go hey [ __ ]
you i'm white what are you gonna do
um and the old shirts that said like you
know
[ __ ] you uh you know
my land is my land shirts that my land
is
my land shirt they sang my country tis
of thee while they stomped him out
sweet land of liver
of the aussie landed my
fathers and they were just stomping them
out i this
is what we believed happened it's what
we thought happened
apparently we were lied to again that is
not what happened
this guy was standing there a bunch of
black israelites
who i like and they are fans of the
program shout out to the black
israelites
yes they are anti-gay and anti-jew but
they're not anti-tim
because i used to do uh tours for the uh
in harlem
and i would see the black israelites and
i would stop my tour bus
and make the people listen to the black
israelites scream about right
uh white people being genocidal monsters
i thought it was a nice break
uh between the apollo theater and then
uh fifth avenue and the apple store
i thought it was a nice break uh we're
gonna stop here and listen to these
three gentlemen dressed like uh ninja
turtles they wear they dress like
splinter
and um so they were yelling
at the covington kids they were like
what are you [ __ ] white fa what are
you all doing sucking each other's dicks
i bet it was good yeah
i bet it was good roasting good
roasting of course liberals are like you
know
no they weren't saying that what
so they were roasting the covent kids
and then nathan phillips came in with
his like you know
the thing they have what's the thing
they have with the drum and they go like
this and it hits both sides of the drum
but do you know what i'm saying i know
what you're talking about it's a it's a
really you know fun you do it
and he comes up and he's like dude you
know he's doing his thing and he's
and he's like i am a native american
what is coming out now what is that i
don't even know what this one is
this is jamaican this is a jamaican one
it just happened i am a native
i'm a native american why and uh i don't
even know how i don't even know
how native americans talk it's very slow
and deliberate right it's like
i'm is this it i'm a
i'm a wise na is this richard nixon and
nixon
it's a c.i.a [ __ ]
president can't say jew god damn it
you don't [ __ ] with the c.i.a bob
they've always hated me these
[ __ ]
j edgar hoover the kennedy family i
didn't go to the right schools okay
so then the native american who is not a
jamaican a british person or richard
nixon i just don't know how to do it
but you know how they talk it's like
slow always
because they know things they're wise
they've seen it and they're i forget
what he how he would do it he'd be like
how how
you are a bad white man or something
that's kind of it
you're a bad why but then it gets it
gets a little irish doesn't it
doesn't it get a little irish because
they've been [ __ ] over more than
anybody really
the native americans sure you got
casinos the irish people of nothing
would just get little by priests and eat
boiled meat and look at our wives
and our wives look like husbands if you
know what i mean
they're disgusting women so
he comes over to the covington kids and
i believe he's beating a drum
in nicholas sandman's face
covington kid and then nicholas sandman
to his
uh credit doesn't while out doesn't
punch the guy
doesn't do anything really egregious
other than stand there and smile
as you would if a guy started banging a
drum in your
i would have [ __ ] freaked out i would
have twerked out if if
nathan phillips started twerking not
nathan phillips
nicholas sandman but if both of them
started twerking like
straight up twerking it's time for
america to get even crazier do you know
what i mean
we're on this edge of total insanity
let's
let the car fall off it but nicholas
salmon just stood there as this um
elder tribal elder
was confronting him i don't know what he
was confronting him about but i remember
i tweeted because i didn't know was
going on when it first happened i
tweeted i went
some of these kids need to get shot
because i thought they you know i
thought like this kid was just [ __ ]
with this old indian guy like why you
[ __ ] with this native american dude he
didn't do anything to you
he didn't do it i didn't care that the
kid had a maga hat or he was at the
march for life i mean whatever i don't
good good for you
if you don't believe in abortion good
for you you know
uh whatever you know
but i do i believe in abortion
extortion all the oceans
um we're being silly today folks we
can't we can't
it can't be serious all the time okay we
can't do three hours about judge salas
and the mossad every day
i mean it just can't i just can't handle
it i don't i can't handle it i don't
know what to tell you
yes everybody's going to kill you sorry
moving on koval's gonna kill you
everything's gonna kill you goodbye
next you know so this kid
i thought he [ __ ] up so i said maybe
some of these kids tuned to get you a
shot
i like to throw a little pro school
shooting one in there if i can and i so
i tweeted that and then the next day i
had to delete that because i started
watching the footage and i'm like
oh this kid didn't do anything [ __ ]
wrong and
we're being sold a bill of goods a la
jesse smollette whatever by the media
they have an ideological
point to make they don't care about the
facts most normal people agreed with
that right
but then the looney tunes and the people
in my business and
you know the people that just exist uh
in a complete state of being divorced
from reality for their entire lives
which is kind of amazing when you think
about
a lot of people in my business have
never met reality they got famous at
like 19
they've had money forever they don't
even understand like they don't
understand how grocery stores work they
don't even stand out like food
comes in and goes in a packet they have
no clue they just open the refrigerator
everything's new and it's colorful and
they bite it
they don't understand the world they
just think when they leave their front
door
there's just people getting stepped on
all the time and and
and they're not being stepped up by the
entertainment industry it's like oil
tycoons and uh bankers and [ __ ] them but
they think those are the only people
that are doing anything wrong
and that uh you know everybody in media
and entertainment is is uh lovely
so these people refuse to really reverse
course they kind of double down they're
like well this guy's the white guy the
maga hat
he knows what it is that's the pro-life
march you want to control women's by
and then you know people were coming out
kathy griffin among
amongst others were like dox this kid
put his fa now if you don't know what
happens when you get docs it's really
[ __ ] up
okay when you get doxxed your
information's out there you get loads of
threats
loads of threats i do you know how many
threats i get
because since i've been doc i have
people go call your mother
call this family stop talking about our
family
why do you talk about our family why do
you try to destroy the relationships
that we have these are
trolls doxxing me pay us back money you
owe
your license is suspended you bought a
house for eight hundred thousand dollars
and didn't pay it back
uh i'm getting mail the government wants
to know where you are
so these trolls dox you i'm happy for
the first time in my life why are you
trying to destroy my marriage
stop talking about me on your [ __ ]
internet show
all of these trolls docks you constantly
constantly dox you they go after you
they go out they even pretend to be your
family
one of them pretended to did one of the
voice things you know the thing they did
to rogan where it's like
literally they can recreate your voice
i've had
family members voices recreated called
me on the phone crying asked me to stop
talking about him on the show
so that's how sick these people are okay
i didn't want that to happen to this kid
when you're 15 or 16 you do stupid
things i did cocaine this kid went to a
pro-life march
everybody [ __ ] up you know this kid
believes
that if we just denied uh federal
funding or whatever to abortion
the world would be better i believed if
i put cocaine up my nose i'd be happy i
was more right than him
but it doesn't matter everybody believes
things in their teen years that don't
work out
he believes in god i believed in a guy
named hector who used to give us cocaine
and then fought and left one day didn't
even tell anybody where he was going
not nice not right but the point is and
he left it we gave him money for cocaine
he didn't get it he left he
didn't just gone he's gone now he's gone
forever thank you and i'll take my eight
ball when you return sir
sir nicholas uh sanderman what's his
name sandman
sandman he followed me on twitter i dm i
said good job no he doesn't follow me i
follow him
follow me back follow me back now i'll
find a way to get all this money from
you
i'll find a way to take all the money
you follow me back you respect me and
you begin to retweet me
pig so
uh nicholas salmon they're trying to
doxx the kid when you're 15
the it's just terrifying you're now the
entire media is getting ready to ruin
your life
okay imagine if like the doxing existed
when i did like
uh tim dillon is doing cocaine again
in the projects with his friend uh
they're now stealing money from his
friend's sister
and they're now stealing money from
tim's mother again
they are purchasing more cocaine from a
guy named buckshot
who they are meeting at the railroad
station
are going to lay down in their beds
coming down off cocaine
furiously masturbating what a disgusting
thought
they must be doxxed they must be
publicly shamed for this type of
behavior
it's very bad the next day they will eat
barbecue chicken pizza with reckless
abandon
they'll fill their stomachs with it and
real barbecue not this
[ __ ] california kind open pit
barbecue sauce does anybody know
oh let's talk for a minute about open
pit please
because we're going to get back to
nicholas has more money than god in a
minute
i would let that nathan phelps i let a
whole indian tribe
beat and rape me for
thousand dollars and this [ __ ]
do you think by the way they look at
this like the white man beat them again
you know nathan phelps and his tribe has
no respect now
they're like oh good you had to beat a
drum in someone's face now they got 300
million
good for now we're just giving him the
land nathan now we're just giving it to
him
how about you keep your drum circle to
yourself
open pit google it get it up now open
pit
i mean he just if you don't instruct him
what to do it's like
it's like you're dealing with a
catatonic here
i wake up i just want to play golf
i'm going to one day i'm going to come
right when he's golfing andrew santino
i'm going to run on the course with a
golf club and beat them to death
okay i'll beat him to death while andrew
santino does the commentary hopefully
tony inch goes there too
tony can do commentary wow you're
getting beaten by
let me tell you about open pit okay open
pit
is a reddish brown barbecue
sauce open pit's blue label so
this is not an ad but i'm i'm telling
you what i like open pits blue label
sauce is unique flavor that people enjoy
right out of the bottle
here's why i like it it tastes metallic
it tastes
when you heat it up when you heat open
pit up it
it becomes something that's like tasting
it is a sausage you put in your mouth it
is the
the de facto steak tidbit
sauce on long island the long island
official sandwich is the bacon egg and
cheese
yes or yes yes what is the official
lunch
dinner sandwich of long island
i just said it on the show the fish the
lunch sandwich
well the breakfast sandwich is the bacon
egg and cheese
yes what is the lunch
steak tidbits you put the steak on the
garlic bread and you chop it up you put
the melted mozzarella cheese on top and
you brown it
so that and then you chop it up so it's
a little tidbit
in your mouth and what do you do with
the tidbit before you eat it
you put it in the in the [ __ ] open
pit
barbecue sauce and sometimes they heat
it up and it's reddish brown and it
it curls your mouth it's like what the
[ __ ]
it is a metallic nasty
brackish just but it's it's my
and and my pizzeria in my town jax which
was busted for selling cocaine
used to call up and they would send you
a white pie we've done this on the
patreon i'm not gonna i'm not repeating
don't repeat every time have a different
thing to say
don't ever repeat anything else
don't ever repeat
so uh this this
this pizzeria would make the barbecue
chicken pizza with
breaded chicken cutlets chopped up they
toss them with open pit barbecue sauce
they throw them on top of a regular
pizza and then throw some mozzarella
cheese on top of that and it was [ __ ]
phenomenal so get in touch with open pit
if you really want to get a taste of the
east coast do steak tidbits
with open pit barbecue sauce
and some fat steak fries which are not
really that good but that's kind of the
fry
that goes with that sandwich is kind of
a fat steak fry
that is not that good but the steak
fries thick and it makes you feel the
pain of the irish
while you eat it um
you don't get this on the west coast
open pit it's primarily in new york so
nicholas sam has now got 250 million
dollars i hope this kid just [ __ ]
wilds out i mean we don't know if he's
got 250.
he might walk away with 100 mil with all
these different lawsuits he's going to
twitter he's going at the new york times
right yeah he might get a hundred mill
sure yeah
nice and how old is he i think he's 17.
17 with a hundred sticks
respect what has he got well
he's 18. he just turned 18. it said it
on twitter okay
so ladies you better pop that [ __ ]
like this these are christians you
better be careful maybe make up a
chicken pot pie and
sing about christ whatever you can you
want to get you want to get close to
that dude
he's going to have a lot of bread a lot
of cheddar what's the new one for money
was it guap for a while people said guap
i don't think they say guap anymore
greenbacks greenbacks what are you
nuts it's from like 94.
i love cereal but i also love health
let's be honest there's nothing more
important to me than my health and
cereal
i love a nice fresh start in the morning
do you like a nice fresh start love it
i like to get up eat a nice cereal get
up run 10
15 miles and then start my day
um by going going to the gym after i run
and then taking a swim and i swim in a
lake i have a lake house
and then as as i'm done with that i i
say mass
because i'm a a deacon when i say mass i
don't give communion i don't have that
power
i say mass and then i and then i pray to
allah
because i'm muslim as well i'm jewish
i'm all of the religions so i have a
religious ceremony for all of those
religions
after my workout and i love magic spoon
cereal because it's a company that has
zero sugar 12 grams of protein and three
neck grams of carbs
in each serving it tastes too good to be
true we all know we'll have cravings
sugar cravings or sugar cereals we ate
when we were a kid
they market them to children that's why
they put them on the the lower level at
the store
because you're on the eyeline with the
kids that's how sick these madison
avenue
advertising [ __ ] are but it's effective
and we all remember these from when we
were a kid
but what you can remember now is
magicspoon.com tim dillon because what
if i told you i could give you that
exact cereal
with zero sugar 12 grams of protein and
only three net grams of carbs okay
sugar is a very insular genic food
okay and that is not good it causes
inflammation
it drives the insulin up and down and
all over the place you know but you need
you want steady steady wins the race
so what you do is you eat magic spoons
here there's many people that are
committed to losing weight but can't
stop eating sugary cereals
many people that are like i'm gonna lose
weight but i need to eat cocoa pebbles
there's got to be four of those people
that are really committed to losing
weight but they also
but in all seriousness these are great
snacks
if you have a snack
and you are really really into it
um you know it's it it helps you through
the day
you go oh that's nice that tastes like
sugar even though it's not you're
tricking yourself
and what's then happening is you're
enabling yourself to stay on your path
stay in ketosis stay in paleo stay in
low carb i don't know if this is
probably not paleo who cares
it's all fake except magic spoon magic
spoon is so confident and their product
is packed by 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked nobody wants a refund on this
stuff it's really good they send it to
me all the time
we eat it it's great my favorite flavor
is the fruity flavor
it tastes exactly like fruit loops which
were a great cereal
from when i was a child you could get it
in cocoa fruity frosted or blueberry
blueberries really fun you put some
bananas some strawberries in there
all of a sudden you're like what
happened to me what happened to me
so go to magicspoon.com tim dillon to
grab a variety pack try today if you
need to if you want a diet
or if you want to just give your kids a
healthier alternative or yourself a
healthier alternative you enjoy my
podcast
you like this show go to magicspoon.com
tim dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-o-n try it today
magic spoon is so
confident their product i already read
this so you get it okay that's
magicspoon.com use the code
tim dillon for free shipping okay
because
listen we all need something to get us
through these trying times
magic spoon is that thing not heroin
spoon
not junky spoon
magic spoon okay thank you
tim dylan shows brought to you by
expressvpn it's a great product for
protecting your privacy and security
online this is very important right now
the government is surveilling you
everybody's trying to kill you what are
you gonna do
you can easily make them [ __ ] go wait
where is that guy
you can use it to unlock foreign movies
and tv shows that are only available in
other countries binge doctor who on
netflix
and the united kingdom were watched
spirited away on netflix in japan choose
from over 100 different countries
express vpn works for any streaming
service netflix
amazon hulu bbc youtube you name it if a
movie or tv show is streaming somewhere
you can watch it
it works on all your devices pretty
[ __ ] cool man i'm using it
i can watch all the bbc stuff and
they're they're really good because
actors in in in the bbc are allowed to
be ugly
they're allowed to be regular people
they don't get paid a lot of money
they're treated like dirt
okay and that's why the shows are good
you watch broadchurch and you're like
these people look like monsters but
they're amazing actors i'd have a
[ __ ] career if i were there
works on all your devices it's fast
there's no buffering or lag streaming hd
without any issue on any device in part
of your house
if you visit my special link right now
expressvpn.com
tim dillon you can get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free
expressvpn.com
tim dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-o-n you could get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free
is that true is that [ __ ] true
it's true they're gonna give you
expressvpn for three months a quarter
a full quarter of the year for free
expressvpn
is that true
is that really true yeah is that not a
lie
is it we're like religion is this jesse
smolette all over again we're gonna find
out it was a fraud
three months a whole quarter free
expressvpn
are you [ __ ] serious that's right
are you [ __ ] i'm not
mad at you if you don't get this [ __ ]
thing you dumb [ __ ]
expressvpn.com tim dillon are you on the
level
yeah is this legit yeah yeah
oh you better get this expressvpn to
give you a whole [ __ ] quarter for
free you can go watch doctor who
for free in the united kingdom don't you
want to watch ugly people on tv again
remember cheers
remember tv before everybody was hot
made a lot of sense
now it's like i'm a hot young millennial
and i drive a cab no you don't
expressvpn.com tim dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-o-n you get an extra three
months
is this serious yeah i'm gonna kill my
mother express uh
vpn for free
three months 90 days not a payment
just free on the arm living on the dole
amazing donkey thank you
i'm joining the hype house i've been
asked been asked to join the high pass
tick tock
um that is the future folks tick tock
um whether it is that app but it that
lip syncing will be the future you know
all the artists that you will like
will just be good-looking people who
mouth the words of someone else
it couldn't get more dystopian and yet
somehow it will
uh i watched whitney houston on
letterman you know one of her first
appearances i think her first appearance
on the letterman
and you were amazed at one time there
was literal talent in the world there
was
there existed a thing called talent and
people that had it would walk on a stage
and entertain people that didn't have it
didn't have it in that degree
and those people would be happy that
there was a talented person they
wouldn't be angry and mad and full of
rage and vengeful
and they wouldn't go home and say i
could [ __ ] do that this stupid [ __ ]
they would appreciate uh something that
they couldn't have like i was talking to
whitney the other day and she's like you
know i saw robin williams
on stage robin williams was so like not
in control of his own talent like
his talent was controlling him i'm like
right that's called talent
okay it's called talent when someone has
a god-given
talent or something that makes you go
wow this is [ __ ] unique and different
it's like
coming from some otherworldly place like
you can't see the receipts
well a lot of these comics now you see
the receipts you can tell how hard they
work you can feel their ambition
i never want you to feel that with me
we're broadcasting from a [ __ ] room
right now
you know i mean this is this is all fake
but some of these comics you could tell
how bad they wanted you could taste
the joke construction the dead they
could tell how much they
suck in real life you could tell how how
a lunch with them would be the most
heinous experience of your life you can
feel it
you can feel how miserable they are the
second they walk off a [ __ ] stage
and you never felt that way with robin
williams people like that yes he stole
jokes and that's not good i don't know
what he did or what he didn't do
but let's be honest the guy was a super
human
force of just raw talent we don't see
that anymore
it's very hard it's very hard to really
grasp
the the the difference now that that
this woman on tick tock who's mouthing
the words of president trump
is being called a genius by people
that's a big we've made a big jump here
and no no particular shade to her or her
hustle
but we've made a pretty large jump from
whitney houston to billy eilish
no disrespect to her i don't want to get
you know i don't want to run a foul or
whatever
group she's in they could end me
but my point is that open pit
barbecue sauce is the official sauce
of the tim dillon show and we're not
being paid to say that
okay and this is why joe has left l.a
because they can't handle that i'm
setting the trends now they don't want
to handle it
sorry no more alpha brain
pit
let's take a look at portland they're
losing their minds over there
we got dhs agents getting people
picking people up federal agents it's a
war zone and what
goes on can someone explain what goes on
in portland to me
i mean it's predominantly white people
it's a predominantly liberal city
and yet every day is is a riot i mean
these people are j
and the problem is and we've talked
about this
when you're an adult you don't talk
about what you want to happen
you you talk about what will happen
people make
millions and billions of dollars just
figuring out
how the market will behave what will
happen what are the likelihood
of this sequence of events happening
versus
that sequence of events happening so i
could
i could write a list for example of 10
things 10 ways i want the government to
function
i say i want this i want that i want i
could write a laundry list of demands
and then say and i want everyone to go
out right and burn everything down until
all of those demands are met
the reason i don't do that is because
i'm not criminally insane
because that's a criminally insane
position to just say we're going to
destroy and defile
everything until these demands are met
until
everybody that opposes us resigns and
we abolish everybody that stands in our
way this
is not how you can do things here's one
reason why
because on the other side of it you have
a very large well-funded
uh national security apparatus
of state and federal forces that are
armed
and well-funded that you're going to
have to get rid of before you can enact
whatever version
of crazy you're planning on running the
country with
and that's probably not going to happen
i mean look how long chas
was around it was a few weeks they ended
up shooting it kept the people getting
shot
they replicated the worst parts of our
society like a police force
these things don't work what works not
much works
that's the other thing so that's
frustrating because i'm not going to
tell you that
everything will be okay if you just
participate in electoral politics i
think things will get better
i don't think you have much of a choice
unless you're willing to just
head into war every day all day
but electoral politics on the local
level seems to bear
more fruit than many many times on the
national level because there are so many
compromises
by the time you get to the national
level but i'm not going to tell you that
electoral politics is going to make
everything better
a lot of people will a lot of people say
just vote them out if you don't like
them
may not work but that doesn't mean that
smashing the windows of the amazon store
in seattle
is going to enact the type of social
change you want
i also think how much of this is
apolitical do these people really
have political aims that are in the
street in seattle
i mean they're saying like stop trans
murder but that's not happening i mean
when you look at who's killing trans
people it's people they're in
relationships with
trans people have a higher incidence of
being in sex work yes is some of that
from discrimination
absolutely but the idea that there's a
group of people hunting trans people in
america is untrue
it's just not borne out by the facts
it's not statistics so when you hold up
that sign
and say en trans murder you're saying
end the thing
i don't i don't murder trans people
i don't vote for candidates who suggest
murdering trans people's good
i wouldn't consider it even if they
agreed with everything else
even if they said well i use open pit
sauce and i love that
but then they said but we got to murder
trans people i go no i wouldn't
pull ever for that person so if i'm not
doing it i'm not supporting candidates
who are doing it well
are you supporting a culture that allows
it to happen well we're going to have to
talk about what you mean by that
do i think jokes enable people to do i
think anybody who's going to kill a
trans person has ever been motivated by
a joke
no do i think any of them have ever been
given a license to commit a violent act
by a joke
no there's nobody on the fence about
committing a hate crime
that here's a joke and goes now i can do
it
that's not to say that all jokes are
appropriate all the time
that's not to say that jokes and humor
can't evolve
audiences tell you what is and isn't
appropriate and you have to work with
where the audience is at any given time
you can be above the audience you could
try to drag him to a higher plane
that's great that's fine i have like one
or two jokes about trans people and
you're not at all about trans people it
was one joke
about a trans navy seal i said that's
got to be a fascinating person
a kid that grew up and was like if i'm
certain of one thing it said i'm a
killer
you know i don't know what bathroom i'm
gonna leave when i walk out i'm gonna
murder somebody
that i i've gotten booze in red state
crowds
on that joke because they don't think
that navy seals murder people they're
like wait a minute
what are you saying and i'm like well
that they're
kill you know they're killers that's
that's the cool thing about them right
not that they can swim
so most and then some blue crowds don't
get it because they're like wait what
but if you listen to the joke
usually most people get it everybody
should get it it's nothing to do
with trans people but so when you're
walking in a protest and you have these
signs like end
this thing that you don't control
and isn't really happening on the level
you think it is
if you want to take some police funding
and and fund social services with it
and you say that the police don't need
all these [ __ ] tanks and and machine
guns and all that [ __ ]
i mean after these few months that's not
the easiest argument to make but i
agree with you i would say let's
demilitarize them
let's give some of that money to social
services most people would agree with
you
but the people marching around portland
burning things down
don't have an agenda that makes
any real sense
it's not political it's i hate this
country
and i want it to change which is fine
i'm with you
in in a lot of respects not really been
hating it but about going
it's immoral it's a criminal state it's
a mafia state
i've said all of that i believe it i
think we protect and shelter some of the
worst people in the world
how that gets changed i don't know
i'm willing to and thank god i don't
have to know i'm a comedian but i'm
pretty sure it's not going to be
grabbing an ipad in seattle and running
away it's
it's maybe electoral politics on the
state and local level it might be
changing your habits
changing the things you buy the
companies you support i don't know i
mean
i'm willing to listen to a lot of
different people that are a lot smarter
than me
but most people don't want to live in a
world that's 24 7 chaos they just don't
i don't want to do
it most people don't want to do it so
the idea that that the people in
portland
every day they've been just setting
things on fire and smashing with her
every [ __ ] day and don't tell me they
haven't because i've watched these
[ __ ] things with my own two eyes and
it's always like a qualifier by the way
it's always a qualifier
when you show somebody video they're
like that guy their lighting on fire was
in their face
they go they're protesting in an area of
the city that's not even crowded it's
like well of course it's crowded why
would they do it otherwise
and then people go uh yeah wow they're
protesting areas it's not even
that's nothing's even going on and i'm
like well then why would they do it
right it's a lot you're illogical
that guy that they're stomping out in
the middle of the street
gave one of them a look he misgendered
someone so they had to beat the [ __ ] out
of him
they took that stop sign and they shoved
it up his ass and they
did that because he was trying to video
them and give it to the feds
i just don't understand um
what these people think is gonna happen
i don't understand i i read their
twitters
i i read what they say communism will
win it's not gonna win
it's probably not gonna win and if it
wins what do you think that means you
think everyone gets
care if communism wins you think that's
you think that's the main goal of
everybody in the street right now
burning things down beating each other
up is the health of others
is that what you really believe do you
really believe that they're concerned
about people's health
how many of them have done any
meaningful volunteer work in their
entire lives
how many of these people that are on the
street right now just you know consume
with rage have ever done anything
to help anybody on a person-to-person
individual level it's a fair question
is it a high percentage of them i don't
think so
i could be wrong you know
i just think that electoral politics is
not perfect it may not work i don't see
any other
i don't see anything other than any
other strategy that doesn't deliver us
into a police state overnight eventually
i think this delivers us into a police
state 100 percent
i think this along with covid this is
the perfect storm of factors
that will eventually push people over
the edge they will accept government
interventions
in larger and larger um
you know uh you know they'll accept
an intervention of the government in
larger and larger numbers until
you know you're living in an occupied
city
and i don't think that's what we want
right and i think on the flip side we
also don't want
like the government being run by
lunatics that are running around in
portland with green hair
and burning themselves you know throwing
molotov cocktails at buildings
and they don't seem to have any
understanding of history or where that
leads
where that goes by the way saying that
european
colonists are the only people that have
ever done anything wrong in history
and ignoring every other power dynamic
that's ever existed
that included slavery that included uh
you know war that included uh barbarism
saying all of that
only mattered in in the post-colonial
era
uh and it was when it was the british
when it was white people and that all of
the problems in the world are direct
uh results of the actions of white guys
and then saying okay but i'd like to
lead now it's like most people go wait a
minute where does this go
where does this go just nominate
michelle obama and
andrew cuomo uh the meatball king i will
vote for those two
the obamas are the best you're gonna do
leftist they're you're not getting bits
not gonna get better than them you got
trump now i don't know and then you're
gonna get
biden who's dead so this idea like yes
obama did bad things obama yeah war
criminal blah blah blah blah blah blah
yeah agree with you you're not probably
gonna do much better good luck
you're not gonna do much better i'm
telling you him 35.
many of you are children when i'm 55
i'm gonna be making these same points
hopefully not to you [ __ ] losers
hopefully somewhere else getting real
[ __ ] money we do fine
but i'm saying that you start to realize
the country you're living in
okay you got to understand the country
you're living in the best you can do
is michelle obama she comes out in a
dashiki
and [ __ ] singing [ __ ] motown [ __ ]
and then meatball comes out behind her
and everybody's like okay it's meatball
like nobody even calls him call me but
it gets me ball
and he comes out and his [ __ ]
brother's there and they're just doing
you know double claps double claps and
michelle obama and brock come out just
just smooth motown [ __ ] this is not
racist smooth motown [ __ ] like we
were like we gonna change the country
and everybody's rolling in and then
meatball meatball and his brother are
dressed like two meatballs
and they're in these socially distanced
meatball costumes so they can't
then they just stop up and bumping into
each other and then
the obamas kind of leave the stage and
then meatball comes out with
his brother uh chris cuomo did not have
coronavirus liar
and they both come out and they both
basically do just like uh
like when the moon hits your eye
like a big pizza pie it's it's the
cuomo's
and then all the dumb union people and
the crowd and democratic people are all
swaying
and then f i mean this is what needs to
[ __ ] happen you know and then you let
antifa do a dance at the end
you let antifa come out do like a flash
riot like
like boom the lights go off and there's
some [ __ ] explosions and
and then they do like a laugh riot and
then like sanders comes out at the end
and they just start
[ __ ] breaking down crazy old school
[ __ ]
like bebop like it's all white kids but
they have boom boxes they're doing black
80s [ __ ] you're like
this is weird but it's antifa so you let
it go and then they're just kind of
[ __ ] going
and they're going really [ __ ] hard
and there's lights are exploding and
it's black and they're like dude it's
like thriller
but you know it's like a weird [ __ ]
version of it with just you know
fat non-binary purple haired [ __ ]
they're not zombies but they're you know
and then the wall of moms comes out and
chelsea handles out and she said tits
around
and she's like yeah look at my [ __ ] and
chris cuomo goes
he goes to eat her [ __ ] and then she
shits on his face
and the obamas stand up and they start
clapping and then hillary comes out it's
the big finale
hillary comes out with just lane and
jeffrey and they start [ __ ] tap
dancing like [ __ ] psychopath
like save you on glover bringing the
noise bringing the function tap chance
get the cuomo's with the tomato sauce
the obamas are fight the smoke machine
comes in there's purple smoke they're
doing a [ __ ] prince number now barack
and michelle come down
and then antifa's flash mob at it
sanders is out hillary and jizz lane and
jeffrey
and then all of them together sing we
are the world
we are the children
i'll vote for that i'll vote for that
okay because it shows initiative
and vision
the only thing i like about myself is my
hair and i'm gonna tell you right now
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left
get treated from home with keeps you
used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps
you can visit a doctor online and get
hair loss medication delivered right to
your home they make it easy
and deliver your medication every three
months so that you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits
a lot of the men who listed this show
probably went bald at 19.
they're just living in living in a world
of pain
okay but i'm telling you it's so easy
you can say goodbye to the pharmacy
checkout lines and awkward doctor visits
did i say that already good keeps offers
generic versions only
only of only the two fda approved hair
loss products out there you may
i've tried them before but probably
never for this price this is generic
but the good stuff this is what it is
it's what it is folks
you're getting a little this is uh this
is what they call the nudge
you grease the palm of the meat you do
you get the table in the restaurant
that's booked
somebody gives you a little tip you buy
a stock you make a little bit of money
okay all right
you know what i mean
somebody tells you your brother's
marriage is on the rocks you go over
there you have sex with his wife
he kills himself you raise his kid this
is one of those situations you just
figure out what to do you see an
opportunity get in there and grab it
this is what it is these are the real
products these are the products whose
name we know
but you're getting them for cheap
prevention is key keeps treatments can
take four to six months or more to see
results
so it's important to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save
so this is for people that have hair
that want to keep it they see it's
leaving
and they want to keep it okay and that's
very very important
and that's why we're telling you right
now um
this is a very important thing to do
okay you got to go to keeps.com tim
dillon t-i-m-t-i-l-l-o-n
that's keeps k-e-e-p-s-d
tim dillon you don't want to lose your
hair and
you know
i mean the reality is if you lose your
hair it's over for a lot of you not joe
he's done well but most of you are not
going to be him most of you
you know it's the reality you're you're
most of you need your hair
or you know you're in trouble so if you
can keep your hair and you can do with a
generic version of a product
i mean isn't this great wouldn't you
love if somebody said to you hey you
know the thing you love
i'll give you a generic version for less
hey you know that big mac you love what
about a generic version for less
hey that bag of cocaine you like how
we all want a generic version for less
it's the same ingredients they work the
same way
you just pay less money and you keep
your hair a lot of people friends that i
have that use this
are very very happy with it oscar has
been using it for a very long time
so you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss you got to go to
keeps.com
tim dillon k-e-e-p-s dot com tim dillon
receive your first month of treatments
for free i'm terrified of losing my hair
i think about losing my hair i just
think i would go on a rampage if i lost
my hair
a real rampage really how much can you
take from me
what how many horrors am i forced to
endorse in this world
i mean if i lost my hair i mean i would
i don't even i would just run through a
mall i don't even want to say what i
would do
but it would be bad baby it'd be bad
i mean i'm talking about the front of
every newspaper
internationally they would be crying
in riyadh saudi arabia when they hear
when they heard what i did if i lost my
hair
i mean they would be in lamonde in paris
to spiegel in germany every paper
uh the most ruthless people in the
entire world whoever they are there'd be
some terrorists in a cave would be like
man this [ __ ] did what we'd
always hope to do and it's just because
he lost his hair that's how
that's how attached i am to the hair
look at the hair
so important it's uneated
and if i lost it man i would just i mean
i'd be opening chest cavities so with i
mean
i don't even i don't want to go into it
i don't want to go into it
keeps.com tim dillon k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dylan i mean if i woke
up tomorrow bald
i mean i would just drive my car through
a supermarket
just mowing people down if i woke up
bald tomorrow that's just my feeling
so i would use keeps and it takes four
to six months to work so once
once it's in there it's really really
good
dude they started 10 a month you could
get your first month for free
they started 10 a month to keep your
hair
man that's worth it is it not
is that not worth it what are you
doing dude sebastian how do you me
remember when people used to have hair
people used to have hair in there
now the people walk in there honey they
don't have any hair on that
they don't have any hair on their head
what i love about him is during the
quarantine it's like like there's a 90
000 cases of covert and the economy has
just exploded
he's like today we're making sauce with
dominic on instagram life
you want to learn how to make ravioli
hey i know you're homeless and everybody
around you is dead
you want to learn how to make a
okay what are you doing over there
what are you doing you want to make a
little bit of frizzy kitty
i know everybody's dead what do you want
me to do
you like alex rodriguez and jeffrey
lopez they're coming over tonight we're
gonna make america up
they got a lot of money so we're not
really upset about the economy
paul what really what i get upset about
is when the pasta is not out then
so jennifer lopez is coming over and i'm
going to teach her how to make alternate
pasta
because you know her culture they eat a
lot of cheap meats on the street
keeps.com tim dillon
keep your hair goodbye
summer is here it's crazy hot outside
after a few minutes i feel exhausted i'm
ready for a nap between the sun beating
down in the heat and humidity
dehydration kicks in fast and i don't
drink coffee anymore and i'm trying to
hold it down on the sugar so what do i
need i need a pick-me-up okay
sustainable
hydrate hydrant is the key to getting
back
up and running more quickly than ever
before top performers in businesses and
sports often attribute success to their
morning routine
everybody that's cool gets up early in
the morning and really goes for it you
know what i mean does the jog the
sit-ups the whole thing they're really
into it they love it they can't get
enough
or they get up with the you know the
architect and he's
drawing his house you know what he's got
the uh you know he's got the blueprints
he goes we're gonna build the building
and that's what he does and you're not
doing that and you're not doing an axe
unit of hydrant hydro created a
refreshing electrolyte powder that mixed
directly into water to efficiently and
effectively hydrate the body
it hydrates you quickly and keeps you
going for longer each rapid hydration
mix has four essential electrolytes your
body needs
listen up sodium potassium magnesium and
cocaine i'm getting sick
and it packs a punch to help your body
hydrate and feel safe and stay hydrated
if you're looking for that extra boost
of energy there's also hydrogen plus
caffeine
which contains 100 milligrams of
caffeine from green tea that's nice
hydrogen is backed by research the
formula was developed by an oxford
scientist those are real they're british
it's also loved by pro athlete's top
performer celebrity and has thousands of
five-star reviews it's made with fruit
juice powder
it's delicious and refreshing and comes
in a variety of flavors
including new summer friendly orange
mango and fruit punch it's backed by 100
satisfaction guarantee that's right if
you don't love it it's sent back for a
full refund
you really need to try it out for
yourself to see what i'm talking about
it tastes incredible and it works
hydrant starts at just a buck a packet
for a 30-day supply
save even more with a monthly
subscription who starts the day with
hydrogen every day this gentleman
you're a good boy
he really is beautiful
he's a terrorist it's my friend's dog
i'm watching
the great duncan
why are you laughing now he'll just go
right to bed
right there yeah why not
drink hydrant.com tim and enter promo
code tim to save 25
we thank them for sponsoring the podcast
drink hydrant dot com
slash tim and enter promo code tim to
save 25
you tell them duncan
i don't even read the cases anymore
they're like uh there's 90 uh million
cases
of coronavirus reported in your house
like it gets closer to you every day
they're like in your uh
on your street everyone is dead
of covet 19. there are 70 000 cases
uh in your family and your family has
65 000 cases right now of covert 19.
uh nobody knows who's dying why they're
dying where they're going i don't i
can't even i don't even know
it's a show that you can't watch anymore
it's gotten too complicated
i don't know why fouchy's throwing
[ __ ] wild balls
and not in a lab with a coat on i don't
know why somebody decided he needs to be
on every podcast in america
why he needs to do every press
appearance i don't know what that makes
no one feel comfortable that this
[ __ ] old [ __ ] can't even throw a
[ __ ] ball
and this is the guy that's gonna save
everybody's [ __ ] life can anyone fill
me in on on who decided that made set
didn't anyone check that he could throw
a [ __ ] ball before they trotted him
out on the field
that's crazy but i can't even it's a
show i can
barely watch anymore you know where you
tune into it
and you go i can't wait what
what is the symptoms now my finger hurts
so if my finger hurts and i have no
other symptoms i can die
and there's nine million cases
where on a ship
that no one's been on no one's
no one's on the ship there's nine
million cases
there's nine million vials of covet
being shipped here
the chinese are doing what
ventilators respirators
surfaces uv light what
you got you got to just stop you got to
say to yourself i just can't anymore
i don't understand i don't know where it
goes i just say to myself
when it when it lightens up someone will
let me know i'm sure the media will let
us know it might be november 9th by the
way
november 9th they might be like no there
are no cases of coffee
that is a possibility they go there are
no there's no new cases of covet that's
very interesting we
okay and maybe not i get it's real it's
bad it's deadly i'm not going near
anybody you know
um it's a [ __ ] vicious bug stay the
[ __ ] away from people stay home protect
yourself
you don't know what's going on after you
don't know why we got this we're gonna
know in five years
it's gonna be books written in years
about how this whole thing was a chinese
thing or whatever
or it wasn't it was a u.s joint u.s
china joint thing we're not above that
either we're [ __ ] both researching
and thinking bro
you got out of there sister we don't
listen we're not gonna know for years
but when you know you're gonna go [ __ ]
right and this is this is gonna make
sense
it just doesn't make sense right now
because kennedy assassination with
oswald ruby
bullets here third this what cubans
mafia
grassy knoll huh why
but years from now we'll look back and
you'll go oh
this is what we didn't understand about
it this is what we should have
understand
these are the things that they knew and
didn't tell us
that'll be a big one what are the things
that they know and we don't know yet
that'll be a big one
100 but i will get out there on the road
live again when we can
you know maybe nicholas salmon just
[ __ ] throws me some cash we start a
[ __ ] podcast network
i'll bring the sandman right on here
just let him go
what if he is like really racist
wouldn't that be hilarious if he gets
all this money
and then he like gets up and he does
start saying crazy [ __ ] and we're like
whoa dude calm down
he's like now that i have 80 million
dollars i want to let you know i will do
nothing but dedicate myself
to the preservation of the white people
we're like whoa [ __ ]
they were right kathy griffin was right
no
i mean stranger things have happened i
think it would just be funny
just be funny that's all sometimes you
just need to laugh there are 97 new
cases of covet that'll be in a few years
it'll just be strange it'll be like
doctors found 19 new strains of covet
on a shoe and you'll be like next next
i don't care anymore uh scientists now
uh recommend breathing deeply and
killing yourself
to reduce exposure to covert
be like staring at the tv the scientists
have now recommended
killing yourself at the first sign of a
covent symptom
and letting your job be done by a robot
scientists believe the best way to
combat robot is to automate the
workforce immediately
scientists suggest locking your doors
and not going outside
for the rest of your time here on earth
i don't know the robots are coming man
and once they're here i mean we won't
even be talking they won't even be
telling people that when the robots are
ready when they can replace all of us
with robots they're going to be like
go out party on
lake havasu party party on the lake
once they have robots willing to do all
these jobs they'll just be like hey guys
party on
party on the lake let's get rid of a few
party time applebee's is open and it's
free
oh yeah it's free get in there all you
can eat free
for a week all the restaurants are free
get in there stuff some mozzarella
sticks and you will see what happens
no no no no don't even worry about
coming into work we're trying out a
robot in your position
yeah scientists have now decided the
best way to fight coven is to go out to
your local applebees for free all you
can eat
you know scientists have now decided the
best way to fight covert is an
underground bed
that the government is testing out just
laying this underground
bed it's about six feet under the ground
and what's good about that
is when you're laying in it all the
covet stays on the surface
so just lay in there and we're gonna
we're gonna close it and you just rest
you just rest
yeah but i don't understand why they
don't just do them on obama
i mean yeah okay you didn't vote for
them it doesn't matter anyway no one
thinks democracy is real
bring out michelle bring out cuomo be
dope as [ __ ] done
done and done i'll just vote for them
just because i'm [ __ ]
bored we can't live like this forever
i made this point on theo's show if the
ceo of a company if half the company
thought the ceo is trying to kill them
whether they were right or not you'd
have to get another ceo
it's just a fact especially if the ceo
played little jokes on them like he was
trying to kill them
like if he was taking the elevator up
and he's like don't drink the water
and then the door is closed everyone's
like see and then the people that
supported him the company were like he
just does that
that's just what he does the elevator
door opens up again he's like
gotcha they're like wha what see
he is trying to and they go no notice
he's a joker
he just likes having fun with you you
would need to change course you need to
get a new ceo of the company pretty
quickly
you would you'd need to get somebody who
didn't inflame
uh half of the country with a v i mean
i don't believe in any ideas very few
ideas
do i believe in strongly enough to
tolerate what's going on right now
whether i wanted high or low tax i mean
truly
what's going on right now like imagine
like like the chaos that's on the
streets right now and then there are
people that are trying but they're like
but what about
trade i'm like
but what about trade
but i agree with the
but allow me to make a point about
personal responsive
it's time to change course that's all
the guy
trump is not to be understood as evil or
good he's not hitler and he's not a
universal good
here's what trump is and this is the
much more interesting story in a story
that i
love because these people kind of
fascinate me trump is the most
successful con artist in the history
of civilization there is nobody nobody
that can hold a candle really to donald
trump in terms of
being a con artist he has leveraged
himself he has marketed himself
in a way where he has held many
positions not the least of which the
president the leader of the free world
that he wasn't qualified to hold but he
did it the old-fashioned way not by
really working hard and being determined
but by conning people running a scam
being a grifter being good at it
you know greasing palms doing his own
thing kissing babies except he didn't
really kiss babies he didn't really
grease bombs
he did it entirely other he hypnotized
people with his words if you listen to
him
he has this hypnotic thing and he puts
people into trance and he
you know he's an amazing fighter when
he's great on the ropes and he knows how
to just destroy people and roast them
and he
gives them nicknames and he boils
everything down to a very simplistic
uh playgrounds type of politics it's
very fulfilling because we're all
animals with lizard brains
and when he goes sleepy this sleepy joe
creepy dead
this and that he's just pointing around
a schoolyard he's pointing at a
schoolyard
okay and and and that's fun
that's fun until there's a school
shooting
when there's a school shooting and
people run around a school with with
guns
and the same kid that's going fat tommy
dirty chris you go dude we got a gut
there there's a school shooting right
now you're
shooting up the school look at look at
[ __ ] sarah over there in the sandbox
whatever you go dude that's not working
really right now we need some other way
doesn't mean the biden's going to be
much better he's probably not there
isn't going to be a much better by the
way
you know it's it's like it's like taco
bell and del taco
i'll make this point this is how i'll
end it del taco has better ingredients
it's probably got better food
but what del daco doesn't have is any
magic there's nothing magical about it
so they end up creating less iconic
moments
less transcendent tastes you know the
cheesy gordita crunch these
these amazing burritos that they come up
with every month at taco bell
uh these things are iconic they're
they're transcended they take you
somewhere else they make you think about
your childhood
there's something about taco bell
they've created a world around taco
bell it means more than food
del taco has not done that
okay but they're
both like disgusting
do you see what i mean they're both like
food that someone found on a floor
that goes into your body and then you
[ __ ] it out
like you ate a parasite in brazil
so my point is whether you go with the
iconic
transcendent marketing
or you go with the better ingredients
this country is still a drive-through
the line is way too long
everybody serving you is high you are
high
there's cops waiting to nab you as soon
as as soon as you get right on that
[ __ ] parkway
and if you make it back to your home
your wife is fat
she hates you and she's trying to kill
you none of that is gonna change
no matter which drive-through you pull
in so i would suggest that you just eat
your fill
eat up and at least you won't go home
hungry